I was determined to be a designer a
fashion
designer my career was built of my
childhood happy place of crafting with
my mother and I dreamt of unleashing my
creativity in an industry that was B
born on style and Trends and luxury it
was a contradiction to my own childhood
of have me downs and no logos often
teased by my peers
I grew up in the north of England
offgrid my parents worked as local food
farmers and I had a realate
understanding of where things came from
we were the bottom of the food chain we
all worked as farmers and I watched our
small wind turbine turn natural
resources into energy firsthand it did
also mean if it wasn't windy I couldn't
watch
TV getting into my dream
industry I'm a very inquisitive person
so I decided to pick away at the seams
and so 6 years ago as a creative
director of mother of pearl I embarked
on a mission to make a fully sustainable
collection for my brand I didn't really
know what that meant so I journeyed from
field to finish product emotionally
engaging with the people in the planet
picking away the chains linking them
back together we all get the notion of
farm to table right we understand where
our fresh produce comes from it's
written on the packet and also from
point of harvest to the final product it
kind of looks the same but what about
field to fashion fashion is also born of
Natural Resources your clothes come from
either a worm and
animal
agriculture forestry or fossil fuels
without worms there is no silk no sheep
there's no wool without agriculture
there's no cotton no trees no viscos and
polyester which is the most widely used
fabric of all because it's
cheap comes from fossil fuels it's used
it's made of crude oil which is the same
oil that you put into your car the same
fuel you put into your car when we talk
about climate change we talk about the
big stuff we talk about Aviation travel
shipping
Logistics agriculture
industrialization plastic pollution
fossil fuels but this is where your
clothes come from and they are playing
their
part take a polyester dress for instance
it is both fossil
fuel and plastic pollution combined
when it's made it contributes to climate
change and its industrial processing
when it's washed it releases
microplastics into the ocean into the
food chain into
Oz when you throw it away it ends up in
landfill and in landfill it takes
hundreds of years to degrade it's no
different than your plastic packaging
but it does give trashy dressing a whole
new
meaning thank
you
okay so how did we get
here we buy three times as many clothes
as we did in 1980 and wear them for half
as long your grandmother would have
mended her clothes but now three out of
five end up in landfill within the first
year of purchase is changed within one
generation and it's set to increase by
62% by
2030 this is one of the biggest
landfills this is in Chile and it can
now be seen from
space it's mostly also made up of unused
and unsold
clothing so Mass industrialization and a
linear production model of global
capitalism gave birth to the notion that
we could and should have it all faster
and cheaper which means we've lost
connection to our clothes we do not know
or seem to care where they come from and
when I say we I mean all of us that wear
clothes but also the brands that make
them when you look in your label of your
clothing it will tell you where it's
manufactured but it doesn't tell you
what was spun woven died finished also
doesn't tell you about the 3.4 billion
people that work in the industry 70% of
which are female often invisible and for
the most part not paid a living
wage in fashion we love to talk about
equality feminism diversity
empowerment we celebrate the celebrities
and the influences that wear our designs
and yet we don't talk about the women
that make them we treat them just like
that polyester address disposable and
cheap and in that search for that cheap
supply chain and cheap
materials your garments here one of your
garments today that you're wearing could
have traveled through five different
countries and up to 20 different
processes along the way chances are your
outfit is better travel than you are and
your wardrobes most definitely
are so we have to choose ethics
too but how do we do this fashion is
born on B shopping more consuming more
when I was at design school they just
taught me to design something beautiful
and how it was made was almost an
afterthought but now with everything
that I've learned I flipped that entire
process on its head so I start with
sustainable traceable Supply chains and
I design from there up some designers
would suggest that was hindering
creativity but to quote the economist
Kate warw worth boundaries unleash
potential look at what Mozart did with a
five octave piano and I would agree
so with everything I learned this is
what I did for our brand I set my
non-negotiables this is the best
possible practices of the supply chain
for instance we used natural organic
farming practices for our natural fibers
and replacement of synthetics or virgin
synthetics like polyester there's many
more but they're just some of the um
Solutions this was also designed for two
reasons it was designed as a kind of
Benchmark for my team so we had kind of
goals to work to but it was also to help
educate the
consumer most online stores when you
shop you can filter them by size color
fit but for us we also let you filter it
by attribute and material trying to put
ethics and Aesthetics in that same
conversation but only once had
implemented this and it took a long time
to do it and we're very proud but what I
also realizes that we just made a better
version of an existing system which was
broken
it's the best of but it's still take
make use and
lose and so now I realized we have to
add another link to that supply chain
and join it all together and create a
circular system and by that I mean so
many things but for an example if we're
going to cut a tree down and we replace
it could the replacement have more value
back to the forest what about if
regenerative and organic farming
practices could become the new normal
and each picker's lives nourished along
with the soil itself and then new links
could be added for every aspect of the
business what if we looked at profit and
loss for instance what if we turned that
into Pay It Forward what if we reimagine
the concept of
success they say we eat a credit card's
worth of plastic every week with the
microplastics and when all is said and
done we won't be able to eat
money for me the answer is very
simple very notion of questioning
everything is key and being responsive
for my actions as a business leader and
an individual is key and for those that
are willing to not think and rethink we
have to pass
legislation on this journey I didn't
think it was very revolutionary trying
to meet my sheep that made my
clothes but it turns that it
was before I knew I was on the news the
subject of a documentary riding Collins
for British Rogue and that gives me a
lot of
Hope but fashion is still everything you
think it's Trends fastpac logos Brands
but to Fashion something is to make
something and that was where my passion
came from and what I've learned in this
journey is if I'm going to continue to
design and fashion clothing I must also
fashion our future the two things come
hand in
hand yes there are Technical Solutions
to this problem to these problems and I
can talk endlessly about them from
biomimicry based dyes and finishes to
regenerative and recycled
textiles and it's important technology
is important but the other thing I've
learned in this journey is that it's
only when we reconnect back to the
living world and look at it in awe and
wonder and the respect that it deserves
will true systemic change happen and
when I talk about the Living World I
talk about the people and the
planet box ticking is green washing and
green washing is
dangerous it's just the medicine to a
symptom and not the solution to a
problem
and fashion absolutely should not cost
the
Earth nature designs or Fashions the
most incredible designs there are we
just simply forgot to
look so my ask next time you open your
wardrobes instead of seeing clothes
brands logos and perhaps your favorite
dress delve a little bit deeper go to
naria and instead see the vast and
unique ecosystem that makes each piece
individual and its inherent connection
to our planet on which all of our Lives
depend thank
you